All right.
Noa Gastfreund, how are you doing?
I'm good.
How are you?
I am fantastic.
I'm so excited to share
these next 20 minutes with you
to talk about
the wonderful hybrid program
that you're working on.
As well as some of the other endeavors
that you've had.
Noa, to get started,
I have to talk about this fun fact.
You grew up wanting to be a supermodel.
Talk to me a little bit about that.
Okay. So, yeah.
When I was 14, I guess, it was my dream.
I didn't realize that it won't happen.
Never. Because I'm not that tall. Yeah.
And no one told me.
No one told me that.
But I went to an agency in Israel,
called Roberto,
which is the well known agency
here in Israel.
And he accepted me also.
I don't know.
I thought that, I think it's a joke.
I don't know. But he accepted me.
But Noa, it's so discerning
because you don't have to be tall
to be a supermodel.
You don't have to be
with specific weight and height.
That's what everybody's talking about.
The whole "me too" movement.
You don't have to look a certain way
to be a supermodel.
So, why is it so far fetched?
Nowadays, you are right.
But 14, 15 years ago, I'm not sure.
And now you know my age.
Yeah, but I'm past.
Now I know I can't be a model.
Everything is right.
All settled down. So, we are good.
And now you're focused
on doing good for the world.
So, Noa, let's start with a little bit
about Hybrid.
This incredible organization in Israel.
The name it aims to give
a little bit of a taste
into what you're trying to do.
But what is hybrid?
So, hybrid, I'll start from the beginning.
It's a call initiated between
the 8200 Alumni Association,
which I'm part of,
and the government in Israel.
Actually, Eitan and Fadi
initiated five years ago and thought that,
why not 8200
with all the connection and skills
that graduated in 8200 unit
can help other people,
which in our situation
is Arabs and Israelis.
So, why not.
So, I think, today,
it's something that it's more common
and people understand what we are doing
and love what we are doing.
And I think that five years ago, people,
not all of them understood the reason
and the match between the 8200
and the Arab community in Israel.
And I think it's a great success.
Because we are truly helping
the Arab society
succeed and merge into
the high tech ecosystem.
And specifically,
into the startup ecosystem. Yeah.
So, Noa, before we get deep
into the workings of the program
and how tangibly that happens,
give me a little bit of context
into the ecosystem
and the relationship between the 8200 unit
in the Israel Defense Forces
through the Arab communities in Israel.
The integration with the tech ecosystem.
Eric Schmidt, the former chairman
of Google, and now of Alphabet,
he talks a lot about
how the startup nation,
part of the foundation,
is built upon these technological units.
And the army in general,
where you take 18 year olds
and you give them the skills necessary
to both mature very quickly,
but also professionally to execute
on very mission driven missions.
So, give me a little context
into what's happening in Israel
and why is Hybrid even relevant,
especially in a place like Israel?
Because in other places around the world,
it might not seem
very forthcoming and relevant.
Yeah.
So, here in Israel,
the 8200 and other units, army units,
are helping their graduates to succeed.
And it's a well known units
that you just needed to record it
in your CV and you're good to go.
And unfortunately, the Arabic community
are not taking part in this play.
And I think this is where Hybrid
is coming to action.
And actually take all the value
and the skill and the networking
of the 8200
that helped them to succeed
to the Arab community.
And sharing the success.
This is what I would say about Hybrid.
Sharing the success within those
that are not, I won't say lucky enough,
but that they don't take part
in this play and yeah,
and it's affected them for sure.
Right. So, up until now,
there is very clear distinction between
not just the Israeli, the Jewish Israelis
and the Arab communities,
but also within
the Jewish-Israeli community.
You have those that go
to the elite technological units,
like you're mentioning,
they put it on the CV
and they're pretty much good to go.
It's like the MIT
or the Harvard of the United States.
And then, you have a program like Hybrid
which aims to connect other communities
with that community.
So, what is the actual program?
And how does that actually take place?
Yeah. So, our goal is actually
to build a diverse team.
I can't say like Jewish and Arab,
and I can't say that it's something
that we are very succeeded by now.
But what we actually do is
under the 8200alumni association,
there are some accelerators.
And we are acting the same
as the other accelerators.
But we are aiming to find
the most talented Arabs in Israel
and actually act as a gift
or help them to get integrated
into the startup scene.
And I don't think we do something special
except understanding and knowing
who are our audience.
Understands their needs
and what we need to do
in order to to help them get integrated
into the startup ecosystem here in Israel.
So, what does it take
to get integrated into the ecosystem
for somebody who's growing up
someplace that is not necessarily
in the heart of Tel Aviv,
in the heart of startup nation.
Yet they have all the potential
and all the capabilities
of being a part of the startup nation.
What is the take
that you're doing within Hybrid?
Yeah. So, I think the first thing
that we are trying to help with
is changing their mindset, okay.
Those people are mostly coming from
more conservative norms and way of life.
And if they don't want to be like doctors
or something very conservative,
they joined the high tech,
but they mostly will join to corporates
where everything is stable
and without taking risks.
So, I think first
is changing their mindset.
Help them think how taking risks
can change their life
and can take them step ahead.
And help them take part in the play
with the other startups play,
the Jewish led startup play.
And second, I think networking,
it's a kind of challenge.
Because they are not taking part
of the army, not in the elite units
and other, I don't know,
other places that I was lucky enough
to take or maybe you.
So, this is the second thing
that we are trying to help with.
And pretty much, the rest is,
launching your own startup is
it's hard for everyone.
Jewish, Arabs, Christian,
but I think we are trying to help them
get to the starting line.
And from there, it's like have them
as each and every entrepreneur on Earth.
Because it's still challenging
being an entrepreneur.
Of course. So, paint me the picture.
How does the life cycle of the program
work from the moment
that somebody may go
in the hybrid website?
What is the relationship between
the participant of the hybrid program,
whether it's mentorship or accelerator
or whatever, until the moment
where they are, perhaps,
launching their own startup
and continuing to gain the support?
Yeah. So, basically,
we are meeting startups
within the whole year.
We are not waiting for a specific cohort
or specific event or something like this.
We are here to help.
This is the first thing
that it's important to say.
So, yeah. When they reach us out
and on every platform via email,
I don't know, meet us in events
or through the website,
we are very welcoming
and trying to help all of them.
Not all of them will join
the actual accelerator of the course.
But we are helping all of them
because we know we have a mission.
It's our mission to help those people
with or without joining the accelerator.
But the accelerator,
the six months program
is our main thing, okay?
And we work as cohorts.
Each year we have a six month program.
The main pillars will be
the mentoring program,
and the content, workshops, sessions,
one on ones, office hours with investors.
And pretty much everything, all you need
in order to build your own startup
and being entrepreneur in Israel,
we are here for them.
We are very listening to everything,
trying to help to do as much as we can
in order to to help them grow,
to help them succeed.
And our goal is
within these six months,
to have them being able
to reach out to investors
and raise their first round,
their seed round probably.
So, this is our main goal
within the accelerator.
But we are doing much more than that.
Of course. It's going to be impossible
over a 20 minute session to explain,
to really grasp what's happening there.
But I'll try.
So, talk to me a little bit
about the highlights that you've had
within the program.
Whether they're personal stories
that you've come across,
or people that whose lives
have been transformed by the mentorship
they've gained through hybrids.
Or perhaps startups that have actually
gone through the program
and have shown that
over these six months,
they're able to form a startup
and actually raise capital.
Yeah. So, I can start with saying that
we are looking forward
the cutting edge technology startup.
The talented people that we can find,
and yadda, yadda, yadda.
But I think we are mainly focused on
find the right people that qualified
being entrepreneur in the nearly future.
Okay?
So, within the Hybrid,
there are lots of pivots, changing routes,
a lot of things happening
within these six months.
And I have a lot of story to tell,
but if I need to pick one,
I would pick Mira Awwad,
which is a woman lead startups
called Mirrori.
And the co-founder and the CEO is Mira.
She's a 2018 graduates.
It was the third cycle of the hybrid.
She joined as a solo entrepreneur.
She came from the business,
she has a business background
with no technology founder.
And she came with an idea,
throughout the six months,
she changed the idea.
I won't say fine, but yeah,
there were lots of changes
within the team.
And by the end of the program,
she launched her startup,
raised their first round.
Now she is preparing
through their next round.
And she is, I don't know,
I really appreciate their journey
as entrepreneurs.
What is their startup doing?
It's a AI based beauty assistant
that helps you put your makeup
and pick your style
based on your face shape.
It's addictive technology startup.
And very interesting
what they're doing there, really. Yeah.
Very very cool.
So, Mira Awwad comes in.
She comes in with some business acumen
but no technology founding teams.
She goes through the six month program.
By the way, how intensive is this program?
How often do they meet?
Where do they meet?
Yeah, usually once a week.
But it depends on the program stage.
But I would say once a week. Yeah.
And how big is the cohort for each cycle?
We accept eight to 10 startups
each cohort.
And is this in a nonprofit structure
or is the equity involved?
How does it work?
I forgot to mention, yeah.
So, we are an NGO.
We take no equity.
We are a non-profit organization
backed by the government
and other great sponsor
that's taking part in our program.
Yeah.
Wonderful. Wonderful.
And so, how many alumni are there so far?
You've mentioned the 2018
was the third cycle of the hybrid.
So, I'm  imagining by now
there have been a four or five cycles?
Yeah. Now, we are in the midst
of the fifth cohort.
We have about 40 alumni.
Wow.
Yeah. Yeah.
Very very cool. And so,
how many of those alumni
have actually gone on
to raise the seed funds
or have made progress
towards a sustainable startup?
I would say 60%.
Wow. That's incredible.
Yeah. Yeah.
We are on the statistics. Yeah.
Well, it sounds like
you have great statistics.
Noa, I'd love to touch a little bit
in the little amount of time
that we have left,
a little bit about your experience
and your journey.
You've done several things before this.
And I'd love for you to help me
understand a little bit
of why you transitioned from
working in the startup, Tipalti,
and going into
the 8200 Alumni Association,
running an accelerator.
It's a very different job
from managing human resources
back at Tipalti.
What was that experience like
and what insights did you bring
from those experiences
towards your current job with Hybrid?
So, it's a perfect question.
Yeah. So first, Tipalti was
an extremely perfect time for me.
It was a startup school.
I was with Tipalti about four years
in HR position.
I worked very closely to Chen Amit,
which is the co-founder of Tipalti,
and the CEO of course.
Which now I really understand
how he is a leader.
This is what I can say, a perfect leader.
Why do you say that?
Give me one thing,
that when you think about his leadership.
Yeah. So strong personality.
I don't know.
Even though he was
in the California office
and we are in the Israeli office,
he was all the time with us.
All the time we thought
what Chen will say,
what Chen will think of it.
So, yeah. Strong personality.
So, at Tipalti, I was an HR manager.
But I don't know.
But I guess you know that
while you're working on startups
and you're doing much more
than your title means.
And I was pretty much the connector
of the Israeli office. The R&D center.
I did lots of project.
And I was lucky enough to join Tipalti
as a 15 employee here in Israel,
working with the core employees
of the company.
It's an amazing company to work in.
Honestly.
And it was an amazing period there.
I love it.
Noa, I can't believe that 20 minutes
have gone by way too fast.
But before we leave,
I have to put you on the spot once
and ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Or that anybody at Hybrid
would describe you as,
or Chen would describe you as
who is Noa.
Yeah. I think authenticity.
This is would be the first word
Purposeful, or in Hebrew tactless.
Yeah.
And passionate
about things that I'm doing.
I love it. I love it.
So, now you're in the midst
of the fifth cohort.
And how much time do you have left
in this cohort?
So, two months and a half.
Two and a half months, wonderful.
And when is the sixth cohort
going to be applying?
We will start next June.
Our application open
starting from early early early January.
Wonderful. Okay.
So, that's not too far from now.
So, if anybody is listening to this,
and we actually had
a wonderful live chat
with a lot of the participants
from Tech2Peace.
Also a wonderful organization
that has a wonderful mission.
So, I just love these programs
that are bringing communities together
and helping bring up some communities
through the experience
that other communities have had.
Especially in the Israeli ecosystem.
I think it's just inspiring and wonderful.
But Noa, I just want to thank you
for your generosity and for your time.
And continue doing amazing work.
Thank you very much.
Thanks to you, Michael.
Thank you.
Of course. Take care.
Bye.